mountainbike fahren damit vertreibt sich
michael van heiß in der korona krise
gern die zeit ein anderes hobby ist
reisen im april wollte der
unternehmensberater aus aachen nach
madrid leider ist der flug damals wegen
corona gecancelt worden ich habe mich
dann mehrfach an ryanair gewandt weil
ich eine rückerstattung des geldes haben
wollte leider habe ich von dem geld bis
heute nichts gesehen
stattdessen hat ihm rein er einen
gutschein über 100 euro angeboten von
heiß aber will sein geld zurück das hat
ryanair war abgelehnten anschreiben da
steht drin leider haben sie keinen
anspruch darauf auf eine
ausgleichszahlung denn wir konnten den
flugausfall nicht verhindern
also man beruft sich auf höhere gewalt
und gehe davon aus dass das masche hat
schließlich geht es hier wahrscheinlich
um tausende geprellte kunden dabei ist
die rechtslage klar sagen experten
binnen sieben tagen muss die
fluggesellschaft das geld zurückzahlen
auf gutscheine muss sich niemand
einlassen gutschein ist im augenblick ja
auch eine zweifelhafte lösung also wenn
ich in guten gutschein bekomme fürs
reisen im winter und im winter ist immer
noch bewohner dann kann ich wieder nicht
reisen außerdem weiß ich nicht ob
zwischendurch nicht die fluggesellschaft
die grätsche macht also pleite geht dann
habe ich einen gutschein von ableite
gesellschaft damit kann ich nichts
machen
ryanair ist nicht pleite deshalb fragen
wir warum michael van heiß sein geld
nach vier monaten immer noch nicht
zurück hat die airline geht auf den fall
nicht ein und antwortet über 90 prozent
der reihe neuer kunden haben bis ende
juli kostenlose umbuchungen gutscheine
oder bargeld rückerstattungen erhalten
die online-plattform flight hat andere
erfahrungen mit ryanair gemacht das
flugportal vertritt rund 60.000
passagiere
ryanair habe bisher in nur drei prozent
der fälle die flight vertritt eine
rückerstattung geleistet allerdings
komme auf 49 prozent
easyjet liege mit 54 prozent vorn
die lufthansa habe von den forderungen
von flight reid nur 13 prozent erstattet
und das geht nur darum zeit zu schinden
und sozusagen sand ins getriebe zu
streuen und das ist schade
ja also da hat man sich jetzt schon
erwartet nachdem die lufthansa auch mit
viel staatsgeld gerettet wurde dass man
irgendwie schnell und sozusagen
unbürokratisch diese themen aus der welt
schafft und das können wir sagen das
nicht der fall
der konzern selbst verweist auf anfrage
lieber auf die abgearbeiteten fälle die
er einst der lufthansa group haben im
laufenden jahr bislang rund 2,7
milliarden euro an insgesamt 6,3
millionen kunden erstattet lufthansa
räumt aber auch ein eine million kunden
warten noch immer auf ihre rückzahlungen
corona trifft die airline hat in einem
internen schreiben an die mitarbeiter
vom 16 juni kündigt der konzern
arbeitsplatzabbau an
der grund die erkenntnis und das
eingeständnis dass unser geschäftsmodell
am boden liegt dieser zustand wird lange
andauern
das bekommt auch marina zu spüren sie
hat seit monaten ärger wegen eines
fluges nach israel den lufthansa im
april stagniert hat sie zeigt uns die
unterlagen die familie aus erkelenz im
rheinland stimmte einer umbuchung zu
doch auch dieser flug fand nicht statt
der kostete nur 358 euro dass dies auch
den betrag den wir erst vor zwei tagen
zurück erstattet bekommen haben ja das
heißt bezahlt hatten wir 525
zurückerstattet vor zwei tagen 358
bleibt an schaden über 167 erstattet mir
die sind betrag immer wieder kontaktiert
marina sah die lufthansa vergeblich auf
frontal21 anfrage räumt der konzern
einen abrechnungsfehler 1
jetzt seien die 167 euro angewiesen
wer bei seiner airline nicht weiterkommt
kann kostenlos die schlichtungsstelle
für den öffentlichen personenverkehr
einschalten die von der bundesregierung
anerkannt ist wegen corona ist die zahl
der beschwerden stark gestiegen monat
für monat
als klar war dass gezahlt werden muss
standen die airlines vor großen
problemen und die rasen bekamen ihr geld
nicht und dann steht es natürlich immer
dann drastisch an
bis im juli bis zu 7000 fällen unsere
reisenden sagen uns dass immer wieder
also nachdem sie uns eingeschaltet haben
dass das innerhalb weniger tage eine
antwort bekommen
von der leyen das jetzt zahlen und das
geld dann auch mal innerhalb von 14
tagen auf dem konto als elke spanner
wartet schon deutlich länger auf ihr
geld vor corona hatte die hamburgerin
bei lufthansa gebucht mit ihren zwei
söhnen ihrer schwester und ihrem neffen
sollte es diesen sommer nach kanada
gehen
wir waren 2018 schon in kanada und sind
mit dem wohnmobil in die rocky mountains
gefahren und waren so begeistert ganz
schöne reise dass wir das noch mal
wiederholen wollten mit einer anderen
tour aber auf jeden fall wieder kanada
doch daraus wurde nichts
anfang juni hat lufthansa die flüge
storniert wegen corona seitdem kämpft
elke spanner um insgesamt 6000 euro
immer wieder hat sie mit lufthansa
kontakt aufgenommen
zu ihren zahlreichen anfragen hat sie
immer neue vorgangsnummer bekommen
über die zehn oder mehr
das geht ja nun schon seit drei monaten
so hat man fast das gefühl dass es drei
kühl ist oder taktik ist eben nicht
wirklich zu informieren
nach einem gerichtlichen mahnverfahren
hat die lufthansa mittlerweile rund 2000
euro zurückgezahlt
auf die restlichen 4000 euro wartet elke
spanner immer noch bei der lufthansa
buch war ja weil die lufthansa steht für
zuverlässigkeit für
traditionswerte also ich hätte alles
aber darüber dass nicht dann ist man
schon sehr enttäuscht wenn zahlungen
nicht geleistet werden die eigentlich ja
unstrittig sein sollten auf frontal21
anfrage teilt die lufthansa jetzt mit
der fehlende betrag werde zeitnah
ausbezahlt hunderttausende andere kunden
aber warten immer noch auf ihr geld
ja natürlich muss man die lufthansa
kritisieren weil das eben noch nicht
geklappt hat und man wundert sich aus
wir haben ja ein luftfahrt bundesamt die
sollten sich eigentlich darum kümmern
und die müssten eigentlich dem vorstand
einer fluggesellschaft die systematisch
nicht zahlt das heißt systematisch
geltendes recht verletzt jeden tag auf
den fuss stehen und vielleicht auch ein
bisschen mehr noch das
luftfahrtbundesamt hat trotz zig
tausende annullierter flüge seit der
korona krise gerade einmal 5 126
ordnungswidrigkeitenverfahren gegen
fluggesellschaften eingeleitet
zuständig für die luftfahrt ist
verkehrsminister scheuer
die regierung hatte lufthansa mit 9
milliarden euro steuergeld unterstützt
nachfrage gestern am rande einer
autobahn eröffnung in sachsen-anhalt
phasen fehler die staatshilfen an die
lufthansa nicht da auch daran zu koppeln
das sozusagen diese ticketpreise
zurückerstattet werden da ist ein
unternehmen das durch corona so in
probleme geraten ist die ganze
luftverkehrswirtschaft dass da mal ein
paar tage länger zeit bedarf ist zum
zurückzahlen der ticketpreise ist auch
verständlich aber ich akzeptiere es
nicht sondern wir machen weiterhin druck
doch viele kunden die seit monaten auf
ihr geld warten verlieren die geduld
nicht nur mit den airlines
da muss man sagen dass politik hier
entweder absichtlich oder unabsichtlich
wegschaut und mal dringend ihre
hausaufgaben machen müsste damit die
konzerne keine narrenfreiheit haben
[Musik]